a very broad I I try to bring in
influences from every source that I can
use my hands on and sort of condense
them or boil them down to some kind of
universal style so you know everything
from South American work to Chinese to
Greek you know as traditional work I get
lost in that you know I'd like to think
I'm influenced from everywhere my dad
was a poet worked at Boeing in Wichita
but I wrote poetry and and there was art
around the house my mom always
encouraged it you know we had our van
Gogh reproductions and Goya is the
little boy with the bird on the string
you know that I remember looking in the
cat's waiting to eat the bird